Welcome to the bar.
I'm a truth teller.
Oh, you can't see it.
I'm a truther.
Yeah, I'm not a liar.
I don't believe you.
It says right here.
Truth teller.
Hi guys!
I hope you guys are good.
I felt that maybe...
Okay, this is kind of... Sounds like a fly buzzing in my ear.
I felt like...
I felt like maybe the eyepatch would go well here.
Right.
Sounds like something Huey Emerick would say.
I'm no liar.
I'm a truther.
Anyway, I've never played this game.
I don't know really anything about it, honestly.
Just that I've seen everybody playing it.
So I was like, I want to play it too.
I saw that you could play with people, so I was like, I want to play with people.
So...
Both games are very, very simple.
Okay, cool.
Awesome.
I saw that there's like piggies and there's fox ladies and there's a wolf thing.
I don't know.
Do your best outlaw accent.
I spit tobacco in buckets.
Oh wait, there's only pigs?
What?
Did the promotional images lie?
Oh my God.
There's a bunny lady.
I reckon.
I reckon there's a storm a-coming.
There's a storm heading your way.
And it's name is...
Oh wait, I feel like I gotta talk with my mouth kind of to the side.
I feel like I gotta talk like...
I...
I gotta talk like I...
Hey now, this town ain't big enough for the two of us.
I feel like Sonic the Hedgehog right now, I'm not gonna lie.
I feel like Sonic the Hedgehog.
Why Sonic?
Because his mouth is always on the side.
What are you talking about?
His mouth is always like right over here.
Good luck on not losing first, Minto.
But my money is on the wisp.
What?
Okay, I'm gonna enter the bar so we don't have to... There we go.
If you get into the lobby, please, of course, don't watch the stream.
Of course, you guys.
Please.
Let's all be...
Let's all be... I know this is the liar's bar.
Let's all be a little...
But liars can still be fair, right?
Minkie, Minkie, Minkie...
Wow, Vicky!
What the hell, Ashes?
Thank you!
Love you, Minto.
Love you, Duskull!
It's called liar's bar, not cheaters bar.
Yeah, exactly.
At least, I like y'all play fair.
I reckon we all play fair.
Right?
Yeah.
And um, I'm actually waiting on like, oh my gosh, you guys.
Before we like start playing.
I'm so mad at myself.
I...
I hate time zones.
I was waiting, I'm waiting on an important email.
Because...
I had an, I had a meeting last week.
And I put it in my calendar wrong because of time zones.
It was an important meeting.
I put it in late.
I put it in, I put it in for the day after.
And I was, I apologized to them.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
Time zones.
And then, I did it again last night.
I thought it was tonight.
And it was yesterday night.
This is why we need the time glove.
Oh gosh.
And they like kept sending me emails being like, we're in the meeting room.
And I'm like, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
Oh.
Is it your birthday?
Hold on.
I mean though, yesterday was my 22nd birthday.
But I couldn't watch the stream because some friends wanted to treat me for dinner.
Oh, wow.
No, I'm just kidding.
May I get a happy birthday from you, boss?
Of course.
You'll get a country version.
Bown, bown, bown.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Peter Thickems.
Happy birthday to the Florida man.
Happy birthday!
Yes.
Wait, hold on.
Oh no, it disappeared.
I think it's your super chat.
Mike Tyson.
This town ain't big enough for the both of us.
Man, my...
My ass is too big...
For this...
For this town.
I'm moving on.
Is there gonna be voice chat?
Oh, no.
No, no.
Let me turn that off.
Is that a thing?
Audio.
Like I said, I don't know anything about this game.
I forgot this is coming up.
I'm not gonna get to play with you tonight because of my homework.
No!
Good luck with your homework.
I think that's character audio.
You have to mute individually.
Okay, I can do that.
During a match only?
That's so stinky.
Alright, we'll bring it back.
I actually booked my returning connection flight for the wrong days thanks to time zone.
No!
I know, it's so bad.
I...
I'm so upset at myself.
So I...
It's kind of like made me feel so...
Because of it.
I was like, I've never really made that kind of mistake before.
And it's such an important meeting.
So I was like, no, please.
A Canadian invented time zones on behalf of my country.
I apologize for making you miss your meeting.
Dang Canada.
Queen's only cause.
Queen's only cause, that's all we know.
But yeah, so I'm waiting on an email to confirm the rescheduling time.
So if I'm like, one second guys.
It's most likely me checking my phone to see if I have gotten an email.
So and if you guys want to remind me to sometimes and be like, hey Minto, check your email.
That would be also very much appreciated.
No, but don't spam it or anything.
It can be like, I don't know.
I don't know.
How long do these games last?
Maybe like every game or something.
I don't know.
Apologies on behalf of Canada.
Yeah, they've been so patient with me.
I feel so bad.
Backseating the business emails is crazy.
Look, my phone, people will message me and my phone doesn't alert me.
When I'm like, my phone doesn't alert me ever.
So I never know when people, someone's messaging me or texting me or whatever.
So I wouldn't get a notification about my, about my email.
What the heck is this?
Oh, there's something sticky under my desk.
It's actually where the lights used to be.
Okay, let's play then.
Um, I'm gonna host a game.
Oh, if it's gonna be Mint Frantum, the Freak Lobby.
And yeah, is there a password in these things or no?
I guess not.
Lobby.
Lobby, lobby.
Lobby, boop.
The Freak Lobby.
There's a lobby code.
Friends only gives password.
Okay, cool, cool.
Friends only.
Wow, I'm scooby.
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
How do I...
Hold on, I'll turn off the audio just in case you guys start talking.
How do I make you shut up?
How do I make it?
Wait, I don't hear...
How did you guys get the number so fast?
You guys are crazy.
Oh, during the match, okay.
Oh, what?
We can't talk in here.
Enter the chat.
Okay, how do I change my character?
Oh, Foxy.
Oh my god.
You just jerk.
All right.
Sorry, I know you can't hear it right now.
What do I do?
I'm waiting.
Ready up guys, I guess.
Liars deck or liars...
You can't hear it.
Listen.
Liars deck.
Liars dice.
Deck is more fun.
Liars deck.
Oh god.
Stop, shut up.
Okay, we'll keep it on.
Keep it on basic.
Stop, please.
Okay, okay.
Oh, we're starting.
All right.
Hold on.
I'm gonna mute it real quick.
Shut up everybody.
Oh, wow.
The game is where your best friend...
Oh, never mind.
Liars bar.
Shut up!
How do I make you shut up?
Oh, voice chat off.
Okay, there we go.
Who said that?
Huh?
Raise your hand.
Oh, that was my card.
Wait, what am I doing?
What's the rules?
I think that they just throw me in.
This is a good hand.
I didn't hear them.
Yeah, because I turned off the audio for you guys.
It was just someone being like, I can't believe I got in boys.
Oh, what do I do?
Oh my god.
One queen.
There you go.
Oh my gosh.
One queen.
One coin.
Are you sure about that?
Huh?
Who the hell is that guy over there?
No, I think you're lying.
How do I accuse you?
Are you muting him?
I don't know.
They can't hear you.
That's fine though.
Oh, wait, hold on.
One queen.
Don't I have to be muted?
Wait, I'm confused.
Mute them.
And then turn voice chat on.
Hey, can you hear me?
Can you hear me?
Push the talk off.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Oh my god, what's going on?
One queen.
Yeah.
I don't think so.
I think that's a lie.
I don't know how to play this game.
Liar.
Yeah, get him!
Wait, what is that?
What does that mean?
Oh my god!
This one's for you, darling.
Close one.
What just happened?
Queen's table.
Oh, we get more!
Okay, I'm looking at my cards.
Don't look at my cards, okay?
You can look at your cards.
Yeah, don't look at my cards.
I'm looking at my cards.
What does that mean?
Huh?
I'm confused.
So it's a queen...
A table...
It's a queen's table again?
How do I throw the card?
Oh, throw the card.
Okay.
Guys, I'm turning off push...
Or...
I turned off push to talk, but it's still telling me push to talk.
Uh -uh.
They're having a moment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
What?
King, baby.
Oh my god!
Crow!
Thank you for the Haka Super!
Oh yeah, baby!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, I didn't get to read it.
Hold on.
Okay.
I can play...
For real.
I'm gonna put down...
Definitely a king.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nod.
Nod Galaxy.
Hey!
Hey, hey, hey.
Nod Galaxy.
No, no.
Yeah.
See?
Yeah, yeah.
King.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I throw?
Throw.
What?!
Call liar?
Can I call liar?
Liar.
Well, ain't my first rodeo.
Okay.
Still a king's table.
Oh, I keep forgetting to turn off the audio.
Wait, how do I...
Hold on.
Push the talk...
On.
I want it...
I want it on.
Okay.
And...
Wait, how do I...
On.
King.
Oh, I see how you select the multiple.
I see it, I see it.
Hold on, crow.
I'm gonna sing you happy birthday.
I wanna read your message.
Celebrate.
I wanted to give thanks.
So, thanks for always helping me through the back...
Half of my shifts.
Thank you, crow!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear crow!
What if I...
Also did two kings?
One king.
I'm still learning the ropes, you guys.
I'm still learning the ropes, okay?
One king.
Really?
Just one king?
Yeah?
I like when you guys look at me when I start talking.
One king.
Throw three at a time?
Why are you...
What?
What do you want from me?
Hello?
Why are you staring at me?
Huh?
Oh, I had pushed the talk button and I wasn't pushing it down.
What do you mean?
Oh, shit.
I can explain.
Okay?
No, don't look at me like that!
Let's see if luck's still on my side.
Yeah, you'll never take me down, motherfuckers!
Bye, Bozo.
You thought, you thought.
What is this?
Oh, Ace's table.
Shit, guys.
I'm in trouble.
You know what?
Probably would be bad to, like, throw down multiple right now, right?
So...
Oh, uh...
Oh, shit!
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh my god.
What the?
Yeah?
How did he talk?
How does he talk?
How does everybody have three aces?
I'm calling bullshit.
This is not...
I think you're lying.
I think you're liars.
Actually, I'm gonna call liar.
Wait.
Liar.
Liar!
I'm calling you a liar to your face.
Shouse.
What is that?
Oh, I was wrong!
Let's see if luck's still on my side.
Luck is always on my side!
Oh,
it's a joker.
Oh, it's a queen's table now.
Never punished.
Why do I keep getting these shit ass hands?
Okay.
Oh, it's my turn.
You know what?
Yeah, I'll do it.
Two queens.
Where is the bullet?
I have no idea.
Liar!
I don't believe you.
Yeah.
I don't believe you at all.
Yeah!
Take him out!
I think whoever sits in our seats is unlucky.
Just another scar for the collection.
A close one.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, so you keep going until...
Until there's a winner or rather...
Oh, what's my hand?
All right.
Oh, I have to...
Wait, is it my turn?
Oh.
Who's the first one?
Who's up?
Oh, it's Skizzard.
Make your move, man.
Did they forget to load the guns?
Maybe.
Why are you shaking your head at me, eh?
Huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, look somewhere else.
My eyes are up here.
Um...
You know what?
What is it?
A king table?
Three kings.
Luck is on my side, baby.
Someone's got a death wish.
I can't believe I made it.
No!
I was gonna win!
I was gonna get rid of my hand!
Skizzard, again?
Skizzard, it can't be just you and me the entire time, man.
Come on!
Ah!
You're gonna live!
Ah, see, I told you.
Oh my gosh, we did so well in that one!
Oh, getting rid of your hand isn't a win.
Oh, it's not?
Oh, okay.
Is it just dying?
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, aces table.
Alright, guys.
Someone's got a death wish.
Are you guys talking to each other?
Like, even though I can't hear you?
No?
Why not?
Why aren't you talking?
Make friends!
What are you doing?
In chat they are?
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna do this.
Two aces.
Why do I sound like that?
Why don't I have a cool deep voice?
What if instead of liar's bar it was freak bar?
I'm the wolf.
Oh!
What just...
Oh my God!
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
Papa bear back there is invested.
Knight's table.
I'm the only one who didn't pick the pig.
King's table.
Okay, I'm starting to get the game more.
If you put down your last card the next person will automatically call liar on you.
Oh, thank you.
King's table.
One king.
How many kings do I want to throw down?
I want to throw down.
This is only true if two people are left.
Oh, I see, I see.
It's only when the last person is left.
I see, I see.
One king.
Chat giving me no bad advice.
No, they are trying to help.
Yes.
Yes, I'm an honest pig.
One king.
I'm an honest pig.
Oh my god, the bear gets up.
Okay, I'll also do one king.
Everyone else is doing one king.
One king.
It was a real king, by the way.
Yes.
One king.
Galaxy should have done it.
I think I'm going to call Shouse a liar no matter what.
Scares me every time.
Do it.
Liar.
Oh, that's not what I meant.
Oh my god, Skizzard.
Skizzard is so over...
This one is for you, darling.
No!
Oh my god.
Did we just play like nothing happened?
I'm next you guys.
It's one and zero.
I'm so dead.
It's a king.
One king.
I'm playing it safe.
Oh my god.
It's so over for me.
Yeah Galaxy, what are you going to do?
One king.
I'm going to sus out Shouse.
I'm going to sus him out.
One king.
Okay, here we go.
Liar!
Sorry, I have to.
Sayonara!
Nevermind bitches!
I'm still in the game!
I think that's my last one.
How do I know if it's my last one or not?
Whenever I lie to my...
Oh, it's my turn.
Oh, it's a king's table.
Two kings.
You only have six shots.
Yeah, but I don't know how many I've done.
I think the top right is... Wait.
How do I... It doesn't show.
So I have two more.
Okay, okay.
Oh, when it's my turn.
Thank you guys.
Alright.
Oh, I was going to say sus him out.
I was going to say sus... I don't know.
Galaxy.
One king.
I think he's going to probably get me here.
But, it's going to be real.
Oh, wait.
One king.
It's real.
Someone's lying.
One king.
Someone's got to be lying!
You're saying it out loud?
No, I'm muted you guys.
I'm muted.
I'm muted, right?
Take that, Galaxy.
Your first shot will be your last.
Who?
Oh, damn.
Nevermind.
You're streaming?
Yeah, but they shouldn't be watching.
That's the thing.
They shouldn't be...
They'll be listening in stream?
No, they shouldn't be watching.
It says don't watch if you're playing.
Oh.
It's a queen's.
It's a queen's table.
I don't know.
Look away.
Very suspicious like.
Don't nod at each other like you know what's going on.
Are you in collusion?
Wait a second.
One queen.
If you guys are listening in this stream, shake your head.
Oh, don't look away.
The pigs are in coats.
One queen.
Really?
Was that actually one queen?
Yeah?
It was?
If it really was, stand up.
Liar!
What was it?
Oh, it was a queen.
Goodbye, crew world.
I enjoyed it.
Here!
What?
You'll never catch me deader than I already am, bitches!
I think they forgot to load the gun.
King's table.
Maybe it's because it's my first time.
The game is being very generous to me or something.
I don't know.
Anyway.
I think that was too fast.
That was way too fast, I think.
That was fast.
Streamer luck, I know, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know if that was a king or not.
It's up to you, shouse.
One king.
I'm basically... I'm a dead wolf ghost in any way, so you know...
It doesn't matter what you guys do.
One king.
Liar!
Really?
I'm no liar!
Yeah, Galaxy, what do you think about that?
Take that gun and you eat it!
You eat it!
Yeah!
Yeah, that was a close one for you.
What is it?
Queen's table.
Gosh.
What happened to the eye?
You know, I had a close incident with death.
And it left me dead.
It left me dead.
No!
You're a liar!
Oh, sorry.
You'll live.
See?
I told you.
Good.
I had a really bad hand.
I would have been a liar.
Ace's table.
Hmm...
How'd you know?
Two aces.
One ace.
Not me.
Gaslight them with the voice callouts.
Wait, what's that?
What do you mean wrong?
Oh, if I say one queen.
Just kidding.
It's an ace.
I don't know.
You gotta be really lucky to have that many aces.
It's... Oh my god!
See?
I told you!
Eat it, Galaxy.
Eat it.
Eat it!
Ah!
Get better streamer luck, I guess.
Queen's table.
You're gonna throw for me, right?
You're gonna throw, right?
Yes!
Ok, I'm gonna call you.
Should I call you a liar then?
Yes?
Ok.
Liar!
You'll live.
It's ok.
You got this.
How did I...
Thank you guys!
Please leave and then... Oh here I can boot them.
Thank you!
I want to be a piggy.
How do I be a pig?
There we go.
Don't forget to check your emails.
Thank you!
I didn't get it.
Hello, hello, hello.
It's the same lobby ID so if anybody wants to join...
Never punished.
Hello!
Welcome.
He threw not for honor, but for you.
To mute?
Thank you!
I have to do it every time?
Welcome everybody.
Welcome.
Please stop watching stream.
There we go.
Be the bunny.
What's good about the bunny?
Cupcake?
Ok, I'll be the hot bunny.
Waiting on you onion.
Ready up.
Oh and look down?
Ok.
Alright, hold on.
I'm turning off sound.
There we go.
Aw, they didn't talk at all though.
So nice.
Look down?
I like the view.
You're my best view.
Does this make me a furry or...
It's a...
Welcome guys.
Welcome.
Howdy y'all.
Howdy, howdy.
One queen.
It's a queen.
Oh, it's me.
Two queens.
We got onion, Lakery, Tama.
Very good.
Really?
Are you guys actually throwing down two queens?
That's a lot to throw down in the first round.
I'm just saying.
You're looking awfully suspicious.
Oh, you're looking everywhere?
I don't know.
Looking awfully suspicious.
Lakery.
I knew it!
You're a liar!
Sorry.
You'll survive.
Onion, you'll survive.
See?
I told you.
Honest sampling.
Welcome to Bamboo Chef.
Thank you!
It's another queen's table.
OK The goats that sold the wisps.
One queen.
Oh, I'm in a different position now.
Oh my gosh, I get to see a monkey.
One queen.
Hey, MintedChat just got home from the vet.
No, Wispu.
No, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Hope everything is OK.
One queen.
I'm a truther.
Don't shake your head.
What are you talking about?
What about you?
Are you a liar?
What is that?
Is that a queen?
Oh, Lakery.
What?
You lived.
It's fine.
Everything is good.
Everything is fine.
I hope your puppy gets better soon.
Ace's table.
You know what?
You are all aces.
Are you guys talking to each other?
No, why not?
Guys, we are throwing down a big move here.
I'm playing big.
I'm playing big tonight.
Oh, am I?
They could conspire against me.
That's so true.
Oh my god!
His first shot!
Tama, you barely got to play!
What is it?
A king's table?
OK.
One king.
I'm playing big tonight.
Three kings.
You're pushing your luck.
Liar.
Look, I was going to do three kings, but then I changed my mind, OK?
Tama, I didn't think you would call me out.
I'm fine though.
Never mix.
But why?
So that I would have a king for later, duh.
Like a real king.
Oh, it's an ace's table.
OK, it's me.
I'm up.
Actually...
Jokers are wild cards.
Yeah, I know.
Thank you.
Three aces?
I don't know.
Never punished.
Two aces.
I'm playing it safe guys.
I'm playing it safe.
Maybe I should have called him.
Next one I'm going to call him.
It's good.
What?
I'm not a liar.
I'm a truther.
See?
Tsk, tsk.
You'll be OK.
See?
You're fine.
Another ace.
OK.
I want to try one and see what the dice one is like.
OK guys.
Alright boys.
OK boys.
Are you going to be truthful?
Three aces.
Really?
Is it real?
No.
What do you think Lekri?
Should I do it?
Should I call?
No?
Why not?
I'm going to call.
Liar.
Liar!
What?
Lekri you would have had me.
You would have had me dead.
We'll get him next time boys.
Literally all three cards were bad.
All three of them.
OK I like how the bear is just watching.
It's kind of freaky.
Dice has no revolver.
Not an Ocelot approved game.
Mmm
OK Wait, three?
Did you just put down three?
Why did you do that?
Are you being for real this time?
A hundred percent?
I don't know.
You smell like a bacon.
What are you shaking your head for?
You're saying you're not telling the truth?
Liar.
Let's see.
Oh damn.
Why did you say you weren't telling the truth then?
If I die here I'll come back and haunt you!
I swear to God!
I swear to God I'll be back!
I'm back.
Anyway...
Aces table.
Alright.
Oh, this is my turn.
Two Aces.
Was it really?
Lekri, do you think he's telling the truth?
No?
Liar.
Let's see.
Oh damn.
What the hell Lekri?
You!
You betrayed me!
Lekri, I swear to God!
If I die here, if I die here, you will never...
You will never stop hearing my name!
Oh, I'm fine.
Nevermind.
Okay.
Anyway.
Queens table.
Nice.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
I was not on the right keys.
Three Queens.
Can you only throw three as a...
It's legit, I promise.
Is three the max you can throw?
One Queen.
Three is the max.
Okay.
Three Queens.
Really?
You want me to just call you a liar, huh?
Because you want me to haunt you, huh?
Yeah, I know how it is.
You want me to die?
I have just three bullets left.
Don't look away like a sad puppy.
Excuse me.
Liar.
I have no words here.
If I die, I kind of deserve this.
Goodbye!
Oh, nevermind.
Baby!
It feels good to be king.
One King.
Is it even loaded?
It sure is.
What?
Someone's got a death wish.
You are really trying to...
You can't keep doing...
You can't... You keep making me...
I'm not going to... I can't keep dying.
What do I do, guys?
I feel like he's...
Call their bluff.
He's lying.
Liar.
I hate this game.
You know what, LightCrate?
You are the one that lied.
Don't look away.
Watch as I die.
My blood is on your hands.
Watch me die!
Oh, nevermind.
OK, I'm fine.
If I do three, they will definitely call me out.
One Queen.
Ah, man.
What?
Someone's got a death wish.
Oh, so maybe your first hand was a lie, huh?
It was?
Oh my gosh.
He's admitting to being a liar.
Armin, can you believe that?
Liar.
Uh oh.
Sorry.
You'll survive though.
You'll survive, probably.
You'll survive.
You got this.
See you on the other side!
Oh, nevermind.
Just kidding.
Survived the worst hand.
Honestly, I lied the entire time.
By the way, I lied the entire time that last round.
Aces table.
OK.
Two Aces.
You know what?
I'll also throw down two Aces.
Wait, really?
That means you have four Aces.
Did you actually...
Really?
I don't know.
Should I...
Should I call it?
I think I'll die if I call it though, right?
Yeah, I will.
I think I gotta call it.
You won't make a fool out of me!
No!
My blood is on your hands!
Look at me!
Look at me as I die!
Onion!
Oh,
I'm a ghost now.
Oh my god!
I can like zoom around.
Oh my god.
I hope nobody looks at my dead sexy body.
Rip bozo.
No, you're supposed to be on my side!
Wait, they can still hear me?
Liar!
Hey!
Hey, guys!
I can make this game.
I can make this...
Oh, you're gonna die.
You're gonna die, Onion.
This is it.
See you in hell.
I'm dragging you down here with me!
I could just be a little...
Ask them questions?
Like what?
I warned her too!
What do you mean you warned me?
You...
You could've been lying!
How am I supposed to know?
Oh, they don't show you the cards?
That's so funny.
Oh!
What am I doing over here?
I'm at the monkey!
You can bully me later.
How do I get back over there?
Excuse me?
I'm trapped all the way.
How do I move back to the table?
I'm trapped at the monkey!
Help!
How do I go back to the table?
How do I... I can't see your game!
Oh my god!
Wait!
I'm at the bear!
Oh my god.
Wait, how do I get back to the table, please?
You're fine.
Can you tell me now?
I'm trapped over here.
I can't get away from the monkey.
Please help me!
Help me!
I made it back.
No thanks to you guys.
Ok, just kidding.
We're fine.
I'm fine.
Liar!
I don't know if they... Can they still hear me?
This was a message from the beyond!
The ghost of Christmas future!
Oh wait, no.
Christmas past!
I wouldn't know.
Email alarm.
Thank you!
Still haven't gotten anything.
So then, oh, if I go all the way over here, then I go to here, then I go to here, then I go back to the table.
I figured it out, you guys.
It says it in the top right.
She was playing a ghost trick.
Hurry it up and die already.
I want the next game.
This is so sad.
I can't believe this is Zootopia 2, you guys.
Now we have to see who wins.
Who wins?
How about you play where you always say the person is a liar.
Whoever's turn it is.
Always say that the other person is a liar.
That means...
Oh my god.
Wait, how many does...
Oh, 4 out of 6.
I'm kind of mad that Onion won.
I died because of you!
Thanks for the game!
Thank you guys for the game.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Nice.
Sexy bunny.
Just kidding.
Nice, nice, nice.
Welcome in.
Ready up and stop watching stream.
It's my birthday, Gordon Freeman!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Gordon Freeman.
Happy birthday!
It is funny how many other people share your birthday.
Alright, ready up!
Ready up!
Waiting on you Lumina.
Lumina, Lumina, Lumina, Lumina, Lumina!
GG's.
Thanks for the game everyone.
Onion!
RIP Tava.
I know, Tava died first try.
So sad.
Let's go!
I turned off voices?
Alright, we are good.
Welcome to your doom!
Ok, it's a King's table.
Ok, hello.
Oh, my turn too.
King's table.
You know guys, you are all Kings.
Rob does not seem very impressed.
Ok, nevermind.
Two Kings, eh?
Is that real?
Yeah?
You got the look of a liar, I'm just gonna say.
I'm gonna call it.
I'm gonna call you out!
Yeah?
Call you out?
Ok.
I knew it!
I knew it, Rob!
You'll win.
I'm sorry!
No!
I'm so sorry.
Rob!
Oh dang it.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
Am I now?
Am I a liar?
Oh, sevens.
Surely two people can't die.
See?
We're fine.
Yeah, see?
We're fine, everybody.
We're fine.
Oh,
my gosh.
Queen's table.
I think Mint is going to be haunted by all the people she killed in Ratwood.
Knew I should have stayed on the pig!
Oh, gosh.
Ghost Secret Reaper.
Oh, man.
Is that really a queen now?
Yeah?
Yeah, really?
No?
Am I lying now?
Ackbar.
You're going to be...you'll win!
You'll win!
Oh, see?
I gotta be careful about this guy.
King's table, eh?
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Two kings, eh?
I shall also do one king.
One king.
Scared me.
I was scared for a second.
Actually, no.
I'm going to do real.
I feel like he might suss me out.
Just kidding.
Oh, really?
Yeah?
I don't know, Lumina.
That's right.
Tsk.
Test your fate, Ackbar.
This might be the fastest game ever.
You got me.
Oh, nevermind.
You're fine.
Streamer luck, probably.
We're fine, everybody.
Gosh.
This is just so exciting, isn't it?
Nice.
Email good?
Yeah, guys.
It's okay.
I checked it not too long ago.
But thank you.
Really, Lumina?
Is that actually?
Yeah?
Really?
100%
I call liar.
I can sniff him out.
I smell your fear.
But you'll win.
It's fine.
Close one.
The taste of a liar.
I don't like the way the bear is looking at us.
You know?
I don't like it.
I will also do...
two aces.
I will also...
Oh, nice.
Really?
So you had three, but you didn't put three down.
Why is that?
You're haunting the bear, Rob?
Rob is haunting the bear for us, everybody.
Don't look over there.
Look at me, Lumina.
Is that really 100%?
If it is, jiggle your boob.
Liar.
You should have done it.
You should have tickled the tit for me, Lumina.
You should have tickled the tit.
Oh, you got lucky.
Let's see.
King's table, eh?
One king.
I shall also do one king.
Two kings.
Really now?
100%?
I don't know.
What do you think, Lumina?
Liar.
Also, Franklin, thank you!
I saw a bunch of...
Oh, sorry.
It was all you.
I was asking what you thought.
I didn't force your hand or anything.
You got this.
You'll win.
See?
There you go.
Thank you, Franklin.
I saw people posting their Top Gaming Creators stuff.
I see me in your list.
Thank you guys.
Nice!
All in baby!
What are you shaking your head for?
Huh?
What do you think?
Am I a liar?
Am I now?
You got this.
If you become a ghost...
Well, not if.
Ghost Light.
It's just you and me, Lumina.
Yeah.
Freak Phantom is at it again.
What is it?
Queen Sable?
I will also do two.
Yeah.
What?
No way.
This is Lumina!
Lumina, you knew!
You knew!
Lumina, if I dye my blood on your head, I will come back and I will never rest!
Oh, I'm fine.
Ok, nevermind.
Oh my god!
That was so big brained.
Wait, I only...Oh.
Ok.
No, no.
I have a bunch of bullets left.
We're fine, I think.
Oh, King's Table.
Really?
Yeah?
It's real?
Why are you looking at your hand, huh?
Looks like you're giving me the middle finger actually.
Yeah, don't give me that!
Um, actually...
I'm gonna call you out.
I'm gonna...Oh, dang it.
Ok, um...
Just another scarf for the collection.
No!
Oh my god.
Thank you!
Oh, bye Rob!
There we go.
I feel like I should have let Rob play another game.
Pokerman.
Welcome, welcome!
Welcome.
Pick up and stop watching stream.
I did win the first match.
But that was probably because they let me.
Here we go!
Just in case.
There we go.
Alright.
Welcome in, welcome in!
Beginner's luck?
No!
It was normal luck.
Wait.
King's table.
So anybody got any kings?
No?
Oh my god.
So everybody vote out Amulet.
There we go.
Alright.
Wait, is that real?
It is real.
I think so too, Doge.
I will do.
Yeah.
It was real.
Schrodinger's kings.
Was that actually a king?
Trash Hulk?
If that's your real name.
Okay.
You seem pretty adamant.
Two kings?
I will also throw in two kings.
What are you shaking your head for, eh?
Don't believe them Trash Hulk.
Yeah.
I wouldn't lie.
Oh really?
Was it really?
Thank god we didn't get to my round.
You're okay Amulet.
You'll win.
You got this.
What are you doing with that?
Three in a row out on the first round!
How?
No way!
Do not sit at that chair.
No, it was this chair before though.
Really, Doge?
Is that how you say your name, Doge?
How do I say your name?
Doge?
Doge.
Dog.
None of those?
King!
Really?
Trash, I told you I would never lie to you!
Trash!
I told you!
What?
You don't believe me?
Trash, you don't believe me when I said I would never lie to you!
I can't believe it.
You...
Baby, come on!
Thanks for the five gifted thank you!
Good thing I didn't put down a... Good thing I didn't lie!
Let all three who died on the first round back for another round?
I'll be ok with that.
It's just I think each person would have... Everybody would have to allow them to go in, you know?
Baby, come on!
Thanks for the five more gifted!
Thank you!
Really?
Ok.
It's up to you, Doge.
What do I do now?
What were you gonna do otherwise?
What do you do?
Ok.
You'll make it probably.
Let's turn all these guys into bacon, you guys.
But not me.
I'm the better bacon.
I mean I'm not bacon.
What the heck?
You guys have good hands?
My hand is all queens, by the way.
Really?
Do you think I should call?
No?
I'm smelling a liar over there.
I smell bacon.
That means someone's pants are on fire.
I think.
I knew I smelled some bacon!
Got him.
We got him, boys.
King's table, eh?
Ok.
Alright.
Make your move.
You think this will work?
Let's test our luck.
You're pushing your luck.
No way!
I can't believe I got away with that.
Oops!
I'm on speaker.
What happens now?
I don't have any cards left.
I want to see what happens.
Oh, I guess we won't see.
You're safe.
Oh, that's it?
Oh my god!
How could you do this, Trash Hulk?
How could you lie to us?
We're your family!
Oh, just kidding.
You're fine.
I'm alive.
Are you ok in there?
Oh, I just saw a doge.
Like the doge beam.
Oh, aces.
Nice.
Family?
Yeah, we're family.
Look at us.
We're all the piggies.
We're the piggy family.
Is that real?
For some reason I believe it.
Oh come on.
Why would I lie to...
If I die here... If I die here you will have never ending suffering for the rest of your piggy life!
This is so unfair.
No!
You should never call me a liar!
If I die I'm not in the game anymore!
Liar!
Trash Hulk!
You will suffer.
Show me your hand.
Show me your hand, Trash Hulk.
He's got nothing!
Doge!
He's got nothing.
He's a complete utter liar.
November 9th is 9 months away from February.
So if your birthday is in November, congrats!
You exist because your parents got freaky on Valentine.
That's why there's so many.
Yeah!
Take him down!
Mission failed.
No!
Never be game over.
Oh my gosh.
Trash Hulk has just as much luck as me.
Email.
I'm checking.
Nope.
Hold on.
Actually, let me check on the... I'm gonna open up the actual...
Wow, so fast.
I'm gonna open it up on my computer instead of checking my phone.
Ok.
Now I have it open, so if it comes in... Wait.
If it comes in, then I'll know.
I'll see it immediately.
So I don't have to keep checking my phone.
It's gonna be haunting all of chat.
I know.
Join us.
Come to the land...
Oh my God.
I don't want Trash Hulk to win.
I don't want you to win!
No!
You have to live!
Doge!
Ok, thank God.
No more reminders needed.
Yeah, no more reminders needed.
But thanks guys.
Death.
This is a death threat.
This is a real death threat.
Death.
The grudge is strong.
Well, it's 4 out of 6.
3 out of 6.
Oh, actually this is probably a better view, huh?
We can see... We can even see Mr. Bear.
Curse you.
Yeah!
Call him a liar.
Call him a liar!
Join me in Amulet.
Join us.
No way.
Doge, next one is his turn to die.
Get him out!
No way!
How is this guy still alive?
He beat the 50-50.
But it's the next one!
I'm scared.
He got my first game luck.
For real!
Oh no.
Doge!
Welcome
to the Ghost Realm, Trash Hulk!
GG's
Thank you guys for playing.
Thank you.
What is... What's the devil rule set?
What's the devil rule set?
Devil time?
Liar's dice?
I want to try liar's dice.
I just want to play this one a little bit more.
Devil is crazy.
The fun version.
Alright guys.
Thanks Rinto.
Thanks Doge!
Welcome.
Welcome Rai Bread.
Masuka and Veeja.
Ready up and pig up.
Liar's dice is less fun?
Well, I still want to try.
How am I supposed to know what it is if I don't try it?
I still want to try it though.
Pig up.
Alright.
Let's go.
What is this version?
I do not know.
Sorry, I forgot.
There we go.
What's the difference?
Queen's table?
Wait, what's that?
What did that mean?
In devil there is a red card.
If someone calls liar on it, everyone takes a shot.
Oh, I see.
Devil card.
Really?
Took a long time to think about that.
Is it a red card?
It is?
So if I call you a liar, everyone takes a shot?
Do you want to take a shot?
Everyone want to take a shot?
No?
Are you sure?
Okay.
Shots!
Everybody!
Is that the red queen?
No.
Alright, don't call it then VEGIE.
Or maybe.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I'm going to play it safe.
One queen.
They are playing carefully.
They are.
What?
What are you looking at me for?
Two queens.
Liar.
A Buddha?
Rye bread.
Rye bread!
This one is for you darling.
This bread is moldy.
Oh, just kidding.
You are still fine.
Queens at table.
Brian, thanks for the super chat by the way.
Is that the red queen?
No.
Dang.
Is that the red queen?
No.
I wish I had the red queen though.
Why are you looking at me?
Why are you looking at me like that?
Stop staring.
Wow, I got away with that.
What?
Sometimes it's good to take bold moves because they are too afraid to doubt it.
I don't know.
Is that real?
If I call liar, will you be...
Why are you looking away?
I'm over here.
Look at me.
Don't look at the bear.
I know, you probably think he is sexy.
But, come on.
Hello.
See, I'm also scared.
I'm also scared to take a risk.
Alright.
Nobody is calling out.
What?
Seriously?
I think you are a liar.
Yippee
buddy!
Oh my gosh.
It's time for all of us to have a little treat.
Treat!
Oh my gosh, I should have called it out before.
Three hand.
That was crazy.
Kings?
I want the red card so bad.
Two kings.
Is that right, bro?
Is that real?
I don't know, VJ.
I don't know.
I'm just saying.
I'm smelling bacon is all.
Okay, you're not, you're not, you're not.
Okay, that's fine.
You don't believe me.
You don't trust me.
That's fine.
I'm a truther, you know.
This place is called Liar's Bar, but I'm the only little bit of truth in here.
And I'm gonna lie right now.
One king?
I wanna see.
What?
Why would you tell the truth?
This is the Liar's Bar.
VJ, VJ, I can't die.
I can't be the first one to die.
VJ, VJ, I can't be the first one to die.
VJ!
Okay, I'm fine.
Okay,
I have a question.
Wait, wait.
If I put down...
So, the ace has to be...
The ace, the red ace has to be...
Like, what if I mix it in a bad hand?
Oh, it has to be the only thing.
Okay, okay.
You can only put the devil card down alone.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Why is everyone playing it so safe?
Why are you guys playing it so safe?
We are only playing one ace?
Is this how we are playing the game now?
Dang it!
No!
Why didn't you call it?
Oh my god, rye bread!
This bread has gone bad.
It's gone stale.
You're no pork sandwich.
Or maybe you are.
Porked!
Nevermind.
Okay, let's go baby.
Ace's table.
I've got an ace up my sleeve.
I rigged it.
I have all the aces.
Everyone else is a liar.
One ace.
Yeah, I have really long sleeves.
Exactly.
What means something as a verb?
What are you talking about?
One ace.
Stop just doing ones!
Take more risks!
I'm gonna take a big risk, okay?
I'm gonna take a big risk.
Two aces.
Am I lying?
I might be.
You'll never know.
Come on, call me out.
You have to call me out sometimes.
Okay, you have to call...
Sorry, I was being honest there though.
I didn't mean like at this moment.
I meant like you have to call me out sometimes in the game.
You can't just not call me out ever.
You'll be fine.
See?
Are you guys talking to each other in the voice chat?
What?
Why not?
Why don't you guys be friends?
Alright.
I've got an ace up my sleeve.
I mean, wait.
Thank you!
GGs.
I need to have my mic plugged in.
Oh, okay.
You should plug in your mic.
Oh my gosh, so fast!
Liar!
Fiji is all seeing.
How the hell did you know that?
Rye bread, become sourdough!
Just kidding.
My hand is bad.
Alright.
It's an aces...
It's an aces table, eh?
What is friend?
They responded!
Oh my gosh, thank God!
I got the email you guys!
I got the email.
Is that real?
Come on Mask!
You have to call me out sometimes!
I wonder if he'll call me out now.
You've got mail.
Oh, do you?
Wow.
I think it's real.
It's real.
One ace,
one ace.
Everybody puts down one ace.
Oh, except Mask puts down two!
Wait, how did you call him a liar?
Wait, how did you do that from across the table?
Come on, you can only call out the person next to you.
No!
Mask!
Oh, Rye is out of cards.
I see, I see, I see.
Mask...
Ok, RyeBrady, you'll never call me... Actually, you've got to call me out sometimes, ok?
Why are you shaking your head?
Annyeong!
Welcome to Mamba Show, Baku!
It's now my turn.
Hold on, I'm going to check my email while you take your turn.
Ok.
Ok, great.
We're all good.
Let me reply real quick.
Hold on, I'm replying to my email.
Is it my turn?
No.
Ok,
I'm fine.
Wait, I'm trying to write my emails here!
lol
Oh, is it my turn?
Ok,
hold on.
I'm typing.
Ok.
Alright.
Me!
Alain Minto!
So what?
Speed emailing.
I sent my email.
We're all good.
We're good to go.
I'm focused now.
I'm focused on the game.
I'm in the game.
My mind is in the game.
My mind is here.
Nowhere else.
I just felt like calling him out.
See,
I told you my mind was in the game.
I also had a really bad hand.
lol
Aces table.
Really?
Is that real?
No!
Should I call a liar?
Do you have the red card?
Really?
I bet red only has two shots left.
Guys, I want to use my red Ace.
Let's see if Rybread calls it out.
Call it out Rybread!
Come on!
I'm a liar.
Dang it!
Why does nobody ever call me out?
I don't think that's real.
You do it too early.
Sometimes you have to fake them out.
People do fake cards all the time.
There is no method.
You just got to feel it.
You got to feel it.
Don't think.
Feel.
Thank you.
Top Cruz.
Oh it's me.
All in on Minto.
Why are you shaking your head?
Mask would have believed me.
I told you Mask would have believed me.
Rybread, Rybread, Rybread.
Your sourdough.
What?
What is with all this streamer luck?
This is unfair.
Ace's table, eh?
I'm so lucky.
He's processed bread.
That's why he's got a lot of preserves...
Preservatives in him to keep him alive.
Rybread, how many preservatives do you have in you to keep you alive like this?
Why was he squinting at me like that?
VJ.
VJ, I swear to god.
VJ, I'm going to die here.
VJ!
VJ.
Fuck you!
It wasn't even...
And then they are just going to keep on carrying...
Keep on playing as if nothing ever even happened.
Yeah, take him down.
Take him down.
Rybread!
Actually, you know what?
I want both of you to die.
I want a double death.
They can both go down because Rybread put that down knowing that I will die!
Hurry it up.
An even score?
No, Rybread, you...
No, it's not an even score.
Rybread, you will be dead on the next shot.
You have one more and VJ has two.
What are you talking about?
We are being haunted.
That's what we call spearmint because she got shafted.
Wait, what?
Sayonara, Rybread.
Your time has come.
Donation for the Minto second funeral fund.
Bye bye!
Spear shaft?
What's that?
VJ the silly.
GG!
Bye!
Thanks for having us.
Thanks Rybread!
Thank you, thank you!
Is it OK if we try dice?
I can't play this game because I never...
Here we...
Is it OK if we try dice everybody?
Welcome in, welcome in.
Hi Minty, you are so cool.
Thanks Jordan.
I want to try the dice.
Liar's dice, liar's dice.
Liar's dice.
Drink two bottles?
All you do is drink?
Minky!
I don't get this one.
You roll dice and then you have to guess how many dice are...
How much the total is everywhere?
Alright, let's try it.
If we don't like it...
If we don't like it, we'll switch it.
Ready up!
Minky.
Let me know when to turn off stream.
Now!
Let's go.
Don't be sorry, be glad.
Thank you.
Hold on, what was your...
Hold on, I didn't see your super chat.
Thanks for having us Mint, sorry I got you killed.
Are you though?
Are you sorry?
It's loading.
You're guessing how many of a certain value, not total value.
Oh, ok.
I don't like that sound.
Alright, welcome, welcome.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
I guess I look at my dice.
I can totally see his dice over there.
I can see your dice.
I can see your dice, Zazamos.
Lift it up, lift it up.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
I'm confused.
So I say...
I say...
So I guess the total number of...
Of like 4's, I say like...
I say like 5 4's, ok.
5 4's.
How is that lying though?
Huh?
Oh, it's guessing how many are in mine.
Wait, huh?
I can't decrease the number.
Good.
I was lying every time she asked...
V.I.T.I.!
What do you mean?
Hey, what?
I have no 4's.
Wait, 3 4's, 4 4's.
I'm poisoned?
Oh, I thought we were drinking alcohol.
Guys, everything is really hazy.
Wait, my vision.
You guys, I can't see very well.
I can't count how many dice I have.
My vision is wonky.
This is this game.
It's not my fault.
Don't call me a liar, ok?
Don't worry, you can't call me a liar.
You said I was cool, ok?
What are you shaking your head for?
Hi, Zezimos!
Yeah, no more poison for me.
Wait, I'm still confused.
I'm still confused how this works, you guys.
I still don't understand how this works.
I have 2 of them.
6 5's?
I don't think so.
Starting out with a small number helps you.
No, we have to make it big for them.
Why would you tell them that?
Because I don't understand this game!
I don't understand the game yet!
Oh my god, froggy!
Oh my god, don't take it!
Froggy, froggy, can you see me?
Froggy, how many fingers am I holding up?
How many fingers am I holding up?
Liar!
Drink more poison.
Oh my god, wait, there is blood trickling down your nose.
I mean your snout.
Is that me too?
Do I have blood on my face?
Do I have blood?
Oh.
This is rye bread.
Sorry if my devil's hand got you out.
Truth is that was my first game ever.
Oh my god!
Thank you!
I have no idea what he just said.
Sorry, I don't know what you said.
I just wanted to call liar.
Oh no!
You got a little something on your snout.
You have a bunch of dice in the table.
If you in your hand, you guess how many dice there is in the table that...
That particular number.
You can't guess a lower quantity than the last.
Sorry if it's rude to send the second one.
Oh it's your birthday!
Because of you I was given Astro Bot.
Oh my god!
Lord!
Lord Risenbolt, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Lord Risenbolt!
Oh no, I think I'm dead.
Don't die!
Sayonara!
Oh nevermind, I'm dead.
This one is kind of weird.
I don't think this one...
Okay, I get what you guys mean about the... It's not as exciting, right?
It's kind of weird, right?
Also, don't worry.
It's not rude to send the second one.
Sorry I missed the first one.
I'm sorry it felt like you had to send the second one, honestly.
Sorry, I'm drinking my tea.
There is no gambling thrill.
It's like kind of, but I feel like it's too easy to call out liars, you know?
This one has a lot of math and thinking involved.
Join me!
Why is my mouth flapping?
Wait!
Oh my god!
My mouth!
Wait!
I'm talking!
I'm dead!
Is this supposed to happen?
I'm a pig!
I'm dead!
I'm talking from the beyond!
Is this annoying you guys?
Sorry.
I just think it's really exciting to see my mouth flap.
You know?
Aren't you a ghost?
Yeah, but a ghost does not have a physical body.
You do not get to see a physical body.
Wait, like talking, you know?
Zazamost, do you have your mic plugged in?
You wanna talk too?
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, it's anyone's game now.
It could be noir or it could be froggy.
Oh my god.
Guessing high is lying because it's an informed guess.
If you guess really high it implies you are confident because you have several ears.
I see.
Yeah, it does have a lot of thinking more in this one, right?
I'm a better looking zombie than the zombie in the new Minecraft movie.
Brains.
Poison.
I'm a zombie and I want poison.
Four 3's?
Come on!
Four 5's?
I don't think... Call him out!
Call him out!
Call him out noir!
Yeah!
Call him out!
I love watching my piggy talk.
Wait, this is the best part of the game.
You're welcome!
I got you noir!
Yay!
That felt so short.
I wish they'd make a movie version of Minecraft story mode.
Is there... There's kind of a story mode, right?
There's kind of a story mode, right?
Can't wait for the Minecraft movie watch along when it comes out.
Do we have to?
Shall we rotate?
Yeah, I'll party out.
I'll party out.
Yeah, we... Oh, there we go.
Thank you!
Thanks noir!
Oh, we're not doing... We're doing deck.
We're doing devil deck.
But if I'm a sexy bunny... If I'm Judy Blops, maybe you won't want to call me out, you know?
Welcome everybody.
Meals.
Jack.
Buglewup.
Alright.
No, it's like Blonic, but Judy Blops, you know?
Ready up everybody, ready up.
Judy Slops?
If you're a bunny and drink the poison, your mascara runs?
No way!
Alright, let's go everybody!
Waiting, waiting.
Oh, I can just do this.
Oh my god.
I didn't know I could just turn it off and all like that.
Thanks for the game, Minky.
The poison made your eyes all super pretty.
You too, Zazamos.
Howdy boys.
Howdy, howdy.
I'm a sexy bunny.
If you play your cards right, you might get a little bit of a rabbit's foot.
I heard it's lucky.
Don't shake your head at that!
Don't shake your head!
Jack doesn't care, he's playing the game.
He's playing the game.
What?
I didn't even get to use my devil's card.
Nails.
You were so close.
Bring it on.
When the game gets stressed...
Why do I keep biting my tongue recently?
It sounds like I have a lisp because I'm like...
I'm biting my tongue.
I think Nails is calling you a liar.
What did you have to say?
What are you talking about?
I've got an ace up my sleeve.
Except I have no sleeves.
I mean I have a queen.
I'm the queen.
You know?
Do you think they like what I'm saying?
Is that real?
No?
You being real honest right now?
Excuse me princess.
You being honest right now?
If you're a liar... Break your pinky promise.
Break your pinky.
Why is Bojack Horseman in the background?
Oh wait.
Why is Bojack Horseman playing knives in the background?
Oh it's a donkey?
Why is it so quiet?
Jack, are you going to call me out sometimes?
Yeah?
OK, good.
Oh my God!
We have a liar at our table.
Shoot!
What?
I said shoot, but I didn't think you would take it.
Oh my God.
It's a king's table.
But everybody... It's a king's table, but everybody knows the queen has all the power.
He was still young.
And now it's Alice in Wonderland.
What are you talking about?
What?
Why are you staring at me like that?
Why do you have such a smug look on your face, dog?
Why is he staring at me like that?
What?
I played the queens.
I better not die here.
If I die here, I swear, I will be back.
I have a body double!
It's not the real me!
What do you mean?
Yeah, I'm a noob.
This is my first...
You probably been stream sniping in everybody's... in everybody's streams, I bet!
Oh my God!
Another Metal Gear ref for the books.
Stay mad!
Get out of my...
Bugle up!
You gotta kill this guy!
Kill him!
Wait, don't kill yourself.
No, don't!
This is not the worst mistake I've made.
Don't do it!
How is it possible?
How?
Smell you later.
I hate this guy!
Oh my God.
Later gator.
That was an aggressive route.
Oh my God!
I don't wanna be the bunny anymore.
She's bad luck.
Piggy all the way.
Actually, I have the most best luck as the dog.
I think I'm switching to the dog.
Let me try being lucky.
She got that dog in her.
Ready up!
How long has it been?
Alright, let's go baby!
The dog.
Howdy boys.
Wait, does my mouth move when I talk?
It does!
Oh my gosh.
Amazing round, Saucy Jack.
Let's go baby.
Let's go.
Queen's table.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright.
Curry Ninja, you would never call me out, right?
Why are you looking away, huh?
You would never call me out, right?
Okay, don't call me out.
Damn.
Tic-tac-taker!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Really?
It was just one frost?
One queen?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
How did I get away with that?
Cool.
I'm safe baby.
Nice.
Oh my god!
Frost.
Frost, why did you lie?
Why couldn't you just be a truther?
Just welcome to membership!
Don't die.
Okay, good.
It's not Frost's time yet.
Yet.
I hope I have... I hope I have a red king!
I hope I have a red king!
Red king!
Dang it.
I wanted it.
What the hell was that?
Did you just whip your head around me?
Do it again.
Is it real?
Be honest.
It is real?
It's real.
I pressed the wrong button!
Oh wait!
I pressed the right button.
Just kidding.
I meant to press the E.
Stop doing that.
It's creeping me out.
Alright.
Ace's table.
I hope I have a red ace!
Ace.
I don't think Curry Ninja will call me out though.
Is that real?
Curry Ninja, you'll call me out sometimes, right?
You'll call me out sometimes, right?
Right?
Floating Soleil!
Thanks for the gift!
Now shoot my little piggies!
Shoot my little piggies!
Oh my god!
I can't believe.
I can't believe!
Really?
One queen?
OK.
What do you think about that Frost?
Oh OK.
I'm a truther!
Real.
I'm safe baby.
I'm safe.
He chose wisely.
Absolutely.
Frost, did you lie?
Frost!
Again?
Frost.
Oh my god!
Guys, I told you the dog is lucky.
You and me, Domenki.
Is that real?
Really?
I'm calling you out!
Curry Ninja!
Don't look away.
Face your shame.
OK OK I had a pretty good hand too.
Dang.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean that.
I keep pressing B.
It's a king's table?
OK.
That real?
Yeah, OK.
Hey, Curry Ninja.
We can talk about this, OK?
Look, yeah, we can talk about this.
Look, I'm a truther.
But, today...
Today, it was just my bad day, alright?
Panda, why aren't you on my side?
King's table.
Actually, I think it's too bold of a move.
I think it's too bold of a move.
One king.
I think it's too bold.
Two kings.
Really?
OK, then I too.
Two kings.
One king.
I think I gotta try.
Liar!
No!
Curry Ninja.
Curry Ninja, I'm gonna die.
Nobody wants to eat dog!
Everybody wants to eat pig!
Please!
Oh, nevermind, nevermind.
How many do I have left?
Oh, I have four left.
Good.
Maybe.
Oh, wait.
Ace's table.
You know what?
Screw it.
You're pushing your luck.
Streamer luck real.
One ace.
Is that real?
Don't look so... OK.
Really?
Come on.
Was it real?
One ace.
Come on, Curry Ninja.
No!
Why do you hate me?
Was the last one actually real though?
Was it actually real?
Tell me.
Was it real?
Yeah?
Oh my gosh!
One ace.
Let's play it safe guys.
Let's play it safe.
What does that mean?
I think I should call him out.
Little lion.
Little white lies here and there, you know.
We call them Disney lies.
Curry Ninja they pile...
Well played Minto.
I think we will do one last game.
This will be the last one you guys.
Thanks Mint.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
That's the dog.
He's a lucky dog.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
Diamond dogs.
Diamond dogs!
So true!
Okay.
Alright guys, let's go.
Ready up, dogs.
Alright, let's go baby.
Oh my gosh, that was the fastest loading we probably had so far.
That was so fast.
That was such a fast loading.
Oh my gosh, this is my first time seeing the fox.
Oh the ears wiggle so cute.
Lucky dog.
Welcome, welcome.
Okay.
Great game.
Thanks Frost.
Queen's table.
Is that real?
Is it real?
Yeah?
It's real?
Really real?
Really, really real.
Yeah?
Okay.
Alright, I'm trusting you this time.
One queen.
Canonically, the fox is in love with the dog.
What?
Is that why she's staring at me like that?
Is the fox in love with the dog?
One queen.
Canonically?
Yes?
Oh my god.
Moonbies.
Really?
Is it moonbees or moonbies?
Moonbies.
Yeah?
Okay.
The game has lore?
Two queens.
One queen.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's on the main menu.
Okay, I'll check it out after this.
Very short comic strips on the main menu.
That's fun.
Is that real?
Are you sure it's real?
I don't know platypus.
I'm kind of agreeing with you.
Is it really real?
No?
Okay.
I trusted you!
Why would you do this to me?
It's LG and I die first round.
So guys, this is awkward.
Mortis.
Sorry Minto.
I would have died first anyway.
I didn't get into the game today, but I've enjoyed the stream today.
Hopefully I'll get in next time.
Yeah!
Hopefully!
I always wish with these types of things that I could let everybody in.
Oh my god, imagine if it was like this game, but with a hundred people.
Would take like a year.
Liar!
Join me.
Oh my god, my mouth is moving.
You're fine.
See?
I told you.
Is it weird that I'm like barking?
Or like... Should I... No?
Okay.
Two kings.
It's kind of expected.
How?
Where?
Who?
Why would you... Why would you expect that?
Minto, you're always weird.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Eat it piggy.
Bring it on baby.
Oh my god!
Every time I have the death howl, you guys.
Every time I howl.
Weird?
Yes.
Out of character?
No.
Minto, have you ever not been weird?
I don't know.
You guys, you have to live.
Oh my god!
Nevermind!
Moonbyes, you're about to say bye-byes.
Howl at the moon!
There we go.
See?
Okay.
You got the power of the moon on your side and I'm the dog and I go...
Howl at the moon!
I used to do that with my grandma.
My grandma wouldn't want to go outside and she would want to howl at the moon.
She would take me to the grocery store and say let's howl at the moon together.
And say okay grandma.
Your freaky grandma?
Who else?
Who else would it be?
Oh my gosh, Pitara gets to meet my grandma next week.
Moonbyes.
Moonbyes, you can't say bye-byes right now.
Oh my god, no.
Oh my god.
Don't fail me now.
Your grandma is finally meeting someone older than her.
Yo, that's so...
Liar!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, AK!
AK!
That was a real AK move.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it was.
Yeah, I know.
That's okay.
It'll be fine.
Woo!
Minto inherited the freak.
No.
This is intense.
It's just the two of them.
So it's like anyone's game.
And they're both 2-2.
I want a mint puppy.
If you get one of those robot dogs, you could...
If you get one of those robot dogs, you could like program my bark in it, you know?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Moonbyes.
You got this.
Oh no!
She doesn't got this!
Moonbyes for real!
Why did he say that?
Why did he say two queens?
I guess you could say AKjammer just called a bowl.
Yay!
Thank you!
Viewers in the chat are discussing a story about the streamer's grandmother who was reportedly a werewolf.
No!
I don't think it's fair because I feel like people...
I feel like people stopped trying because I said it was last game, you know?
There's probably people who are just like, no I didn't try again because I...
Because I...
Kevin, also biggest mid fan.
If you guys can keep coming in, leaving and coming in...
You guys can come say hi.
Hi!
You guys can come in, say hi and leave.
And then lots of people can come in.
No, I didn't try again.
See?
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I was just like.
I don't think it would be right for me to do another game.
I'm sorry as much as I'm so happy that you guys got in.
I'm so sorry I did say it was last game.
There's probably people that stopped trying to get in.
Also, hi Kay!
That's the second time in a week Mike Tyson got destroyed.
Doom the fireman.
Bye Minto.
Bye!
Let Mike Tyson play!
But then it's not fair to the people that have been coming in and leaving.
Let him.
Last one for the legend.
Are you guys OK with that?
It's OK, I left.
1v1 Mike Tyson?
Can I do that?
Why is the music so epic?
I like how Kevin just keeps coming and leaving and coming.
Yes?
Alright, ready up boys.
Ready up.
The music is for him.
Can we 1v1?
Is it possible?
I don't want anyone to feel like they're getting screwed over, you know?
Guys, Minto hates us.
There's a Metal Gear Solid Snake password.
What are you talking about?
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
I can hear myself!
I hear me.
Hello?
Who am I hearing?
Oh my God, there we go.
Alright.
Real LG everybody.
Realist LG.
Realist LG everybody.
Mike Tyson, you OK?
Eating Mike Tyson's ass?
Are you alive?
OK.
Ace's table?
I don't know.
You know what?
Liar.
I'm calling liar.
Biggest Mint fan.
Why would you lie about that to me?
Bring it on.
I big brained that you guys.
Hmm.
Don't ever lie to Minto.
Never lie to Minto.
What is it?
King's table?
OK.
Alright.
Your move, Kevin.
Oh, just kidding.
Biggest Mint fan.
I saw your move.
Oh...
Two Kings.
One King.
I got away with that.
What are you going to do?
No!
I wanted to do my turn!
Hmm.
Oof.
You shouldn't have called him out, man.
I was stuck in text chat.
Alright.
Queen's table, eh?
This game is so fun.
I used to play a lot of cheat on Neopets when I was a kid.
Oh my god, who said yippee over there?
Yippee!
Queen's table.
Two Queens.
I can't believe I'm in a game with my Yoshi.
Believe it.
Datebayo.
Yeah, did you guys ever play cheat?
You cheated in Neopets?
No, I played cheat.
It was a game.
Is that real?
Maybe he is playing it safe.
Liar!
You said no!
I swear to god, I won't die.
I will never actually die.
Don't die, Minto.
I never actually die.
I always come back.
King's table, eh?
Two Kings.
Date Minto.
Datebayo.
Someone's got a death wish.
Is that real?
Is it really real?
Yeah?
No?
I knew it.
One King.
I will also join you in cheating.
I mean...
Three Kings.
Two Kings.
He just let me get away with it.
Down to you guys.
One King.
What if everybody puts down their cards with no one...
Someone's got to call someone out.
Will it be like the...
One King.
Someone...the last person who goes...
Says...is the liar or whatever.
It auto calls liar.
Oh my god, Kevin.
Kevin!
This one's for you, darling.
Bacon, bacon!
For dinner!
Close one.
Breakfast for dinner, baby.
Forget to call people out.
I like how it just says biggest mint.
Doesn't even say the rest.
Just biggest mint.
Ace's table.
Three Aces.
What?
You call me out now?
Why would you do that?
Why?
I always come back.
I always come back!
Mike Tyson's ass you have to win.
You have to eat it.
Eat it!
I need another eye patch now.
I'm not so sure you are good at this game.
What are you talking about?
It's partial luck, isn't it?
Partial luck.
Since Minto died, going to take a photo with her.
What are you talking about?
Don't take a photo of my corpse.
What?
It's so mint over.
Why the one time you have to call me out?
Oh my god.
Kevin!
Join me Kevin!
Look at me.
Don't I look so relaxed now that I'm dead?
Yeah, I know.
Taking a good old nap.
Too bad for you buddy.
I always die!
Doesn't anybody care that I'm lying here?
Will someone put out my cigar?
Three kings!
Oh my god, liar!
Someone's got a death wish.
Thank you for the game, Minto.
Glad to have played with my Kamiyoshi.
Thanks, Splatterplace!
It was so fun.
Oh my god.
Kevin?
Kevin.
Actually, mine was a blank.
So I'm actually still alive.
Can you guys give me some cards?
No?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, give me some cards.
I want to play the game.
The mouth moving is freaking me out.
It's so funny.
Let's see from another angle.
Let's see from the bear angle maybe.
Oh, you can't see me.
Just kidding.
Two aces!
Oh come on.
Come on.
You are a liar to surpass the liar.
I name you Big Liar!
Liar, liar.
Pants on fire.
Oops.
Oh my god, Kevin.
Kevin!
Wow.
I wish that were my gun.
You should have switched with me.
What the hell?
Don't laugh!
Don't laugh at that!
This is messed up.
Hackjammer.
Look at the bamboo ship!
Thanks for playing with me.
Kevin stole the streamer luck.
Kevin stole the precious thing.
Use your revival pill.
My river.
Oh my god.
Who would have thunk?
All three cards.
Take it.
Eat it.
Pork!
Get porked!
Liar, liar.
Minko on fire.
What's the name of the name?
Wait, that's the rest of the name we can't see.
Biggest Mint Liar.
They call me John Pork for a reason.
No, they call you...they call you eating Mike Tyson's ass.
You can never change your name.
Bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop.
Alright.
Liar.
I think.
If you are a big fan, if you are my biggest fan, you call him out.
Yeah.
I'm summoning...I'm telling you from beyond the grave.
He's a liar and a cheat.
Don't just stare at my dead body.
Do something!
Call him out!
What?
Senpai, no!
Why didn't you listen to me?
Oh my god!
How many does he have, Mike Tyson?
Oh, this is Mike Tyson's first.
You'll be fine.
It's your first one.
Hey, don't get too relaxed, OK?
E-M-T-A.
Is that what you guys call him?
It's so funny.
Two kings.
Liar.
Oh my god!
I called.
I told you.
See?
This is why you always listen to Minto.
This is why you listen to Minto, everybody.
Sayonara!
Just kidding.
I psyched you up there, didn't I?
You were really scared, weren't you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
I got you, buddy.
You got me there, didn't I?
Say psych right now.
Psych!
This kicks me out because this is a pig's table.
They are just like, no dogs allowed.
Only pigs here.
Would you guys rather be a dog or a pig?
Oh my god!
Uh-oh.
This might be it for you.
Biggest mint.
What the hell are you doing to that gun?
No pork.
Only pork.
A pig because they live best in animal farm.
Like the book?
Dog.
Someone on my table says, Minto, turn on my liar inhibitor.
Freak you with the gun.
That's my freak.
You can be a pet as a dog.
You can be a pet as a pig too.
I've seen people walk their pet pigs before.
I don't know.
Kevin, what do you think?
No?
Call it out.
What?
What happened to calling it out?
This is messed up.
I love when dogs are really weird about like...
Ripperoni.
Kevin!
Kevin, why didn't you give me your gun?
Plot twist.
Mint's gun was loaded.
But yeah, I love when dogs are really stupid when like...
You know, they're like... Okay, so I went... I took a walk today.
And there was someone walking their dog.
And the dog just kind of was like stopped.
And stared at me like...
And then they like stare for a second and then they just like take off.
For no reason.
They're just like...
And like run away.
They're so funny.
Dogs can see ghosts.
That was probably why he was so shocked.
I didn't think about that.
He saw a ghost.
But he wouldn't know I'm a ghost.
Probably.
Right?
What are you guys doing?
Come on.
Oh my god!
Kevin.
Kevin!
Sayonara, Kevin!
Wait, what if... It could be a double blow.
Oh my god!
It could be...
No!
GG's everybody.
Wait, how do I leave?
Oh, there we go.
That was crazy!
He's the main character.
To take out two in one shot!
Literally two birds with one stone.
Mike Tyson gets his revenge!
Well, you're not Mike Tyson.
You're eating his ass.
What a peach indeed.
Hold on, I want to see the table stories.
Oh look!
People say it was an accident.
But I've never heard him talk about it.
Since then, there's been no room for anyone else in his life.
Not even himself.
She looks sad all the time.
She grew up without anyone.
She fell deeply in love, but she has no luck.
All the things that we do for love.
Had to let Mike win after what happened with Jake.
Kevin, was that you playing with us?
Thank you!
What about him?
You don't want to know.
He's just dumb?
It's such a shame.
There's nothing harder than living with guilt.
Well, what can you do?
When he needs to man up, he didn't.
Now he has to live with that.
Oh my god, he already drank the poison.
What about the money?
He didn't leave anything.
Not a house, not a single penny.
Interesting, isn't it?
Now she gambles every night.
He's not like the others.
He loves the life.
Maybe a little too much.
I'm going to enter just so we don't have to listen to those...
Thanks for doing one more game, Minky.
Thanks for joining everybody.
This was a lot of fun!
I want to play more games together, so...
If you didn't get into this one, we'll do some more in the future.
Sorry for those who died first round.
I also died first round sometimes.
I trusted you, Kevin!
Also GG's.
GG!
I don't know if he answered this question before.
Have you seen Planes, Trains and Automobiles?
It's a Thanksgiving movie.
I don't think I have.
Metal Gear Online next.
We gotta make a server!
We gotta make a server.
I love watching Liar's Bar.
It's so fun to watch.
It is really fun to watch, isn't it?
I didn't watch it, but even watching you guys play when I was dead was so fun.
Alexander, thanks for the ping!
Thank you.
That's John Candy.
Who the heck is John Candy?
That is the most staged name I've ever heard in my life.
MGO doesn't need a server.
Oh, we're talking about... Sorry, I was thinking of 3.
I wasn't feeling the greatest today, but this stream cheered me up.
I hope you feel better.
And also, to everybody who joined and left at that last round...
Like Tilda, I remember you.
There was someone else.
There was one other person.
But...
I hope... I really hope you can get in.
I feel so bad.
I feel honestly so bad for the people that joined and left.
I'm so sorry.
But thank you.
It's okay.
SqueakyBoosh, it was your birthday yesterday.
Happy belated birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, SqueakyMoose.
Their memory will remain in the VOD.
Yes, we salute thee.
But yeah, thank you guys.
Thank you.
I had so much fun.
And if I see you tomorrow, I'll see you tomorrow.
And if I don't see you tomorrow, I'll see you next time I see you.
And I'm going to go to my important meeting.
I won't miss it this time.
I can't.
Otsumito!
Thank you guys.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Thank you guys.
I'm just going to exit out of the game.
OK.
Yeah.
Bye!
Sorry.